certains sont venus de dakar pour
entendre ce verdict les familles
sénégalaises de deux hommes morts dans
cet incendie sont là pour rendre hommage
à leurs proches disparus
quinze ans la peine est alors prononcé
mais elles ne sont pas la douleur de
factures traitées fait de mes enfants et
moi aussi
ah ouais
nous manque beaucoup
quant à eux n'a les familles des accusés
sont aussi présentes dans la salle
al'annonce de ce verdict elle se rue sur
leurs enfants
pour les réconforter la cour d'assises
n'a donc pas suivi les réquisitions de
l'avocat général qui avait demandé au
nom de la société 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle
mais pour les avocats de rémi kukulinski
et de nicolas dos reis perdant c'est
encore trop l'appel est envisagé des
réquisitions à 20 ans me semble
particulièrement sévère elle à peine me
semble très très lourde très lourde
donc effectivement cet appel est
envisagé très sérieusement on voit on va
en discuter sereinement
on va aller le voir et puis ont discuté
avec lui on va prendre une décision mais
je n'exclus pas un second procès
la cour a assorti ce verdict d'une peine
de sûreté des deux tiers
les accusés devraient donc faire au
moins dix ans de prison
ils ont maintenant dix jours pour faire
appel une décision redoutée par les
parties civiles
j'ignore s'ils feront appel ou pas mais
ce n'est pas souhaitable
ce n'est pas souhaité non plus de
revivre ce que nous avons vécu pendant
trois semaines mais si c'est leur choix
nous le respecterons
après dix jours de procès une même
sentence pour les deux cousins mais une
question demeure qui a mis le feu à
cette poubelle dix jours de procès
n'auront pas permis de lever le voile